luis fernandez ça continue ça bilbao et
c'est toujours la même un peu quand même
c'est bien ça la met comme sur le final
bon là j'ai ma façon d'être façon de
nous qu'on pourrait être le bon des fois
c'est un peu avec un peu plus simple si
vite et maintenant alors luis fernandez
avait déclaré moi ce que j'aime c'est
rencontrer des gens dans ce métier eh
ben on va vous nous parler des gens que
vous avez rencontrées on va passer à
l'interview ouzou
ça bouge et qui est un petit peu oui il
y a peu bougé on n'accouche pas pendant
le jean galle bombes des districts
voisins intervenus je te connais je me
l'imaginais qu'elle a été bouffé par un
requin à norman il se serait bien
galella votre bien que dans les grosses
pinces désossé sucer moi je fais des
business plan jacques toucher les biceps
de peggy 49 jours au revoir la mer comme
axel bauer touché gershom dira rien d'un
jacques doriot et approches 2010 lui que
je fais visage
bien alors vous êtes prêt luis allons-y
alors on y va où vous vous allez me
répondre franchement ce qui si on dit la
guerre il la vérité rien que la vérité
rien que la vérité
vous avez dit franchement ce que vous
pensez des gens que je vais vous citer
ça commence fort arthur choses simples
c'est un bon entraîneur accises et ses
méthodes et quoi ces méthodes ça peut
plaire et ça peut déplaire du champ ça
promet
non c'est vrai que j'ai vu comment
entraîneur au matra il était assez dur
ouais c'est ça sexy exigeant qu'on mail
puis bon et c'est vrai que je ne parle
pas et ne parle pas beaucoup
ouais on continue michel denisot mon
président m'a alors avec lequel je ça
c'est un peu lent se garder de bonnes
relations c'est peut-être peut-être pas
compris au début c'est peut-être un peu
mieux compris eau pour la fin est
certainement on aurait pu continuer
ensemble le prochain annoncé jean louis
piette le président délégué du matra
racing
je crois que avec le temps il est pas
vous l'aimez bien que l'agent mais je
les lui quelques pas où il a il a quand
même reconnu quelque part qui s'était
trompé sur mon sort bon il faut lui
rendre mérite il faut normalement je
sens qu'il a reconnu que c'était la
république s'était trompé son moteur tu
as compris piette guy roux voilà un
homme un grand malin et intelligent fort
il sait ce qu'il veut il sait ce qu'il
fait il manipule bien qu'il dirige bien
et c'est un homme auquel ils m'ont
personnellement je le respecte et on lui
a fait quand il était quand calmes et
aller jouer à auxerre guy roux il a émis
la chaleur à fond dans l'est dans les
larmes
il a un peu des méthodes à lui lorsque
mais maintenant les méthodes guy roux à
auxerre c'est de mettre dans les plus
mauvaises conditions l'adversaire voilà
alors relativement quand on était à
auxerre j écoute il y aura un retour
énorme pour le retour pour retourner
dans a compté une séance vidéo gardien
du stade jeudi parce que le banc de
touche d'auxerre qui est il est
relativement plus balle celui de
l'adversaire que sur le sien le chien
est surplombé lui l'adversaire il au ras
du sol
c'est pas normal tu rien
on voit bien le jeu et toi tu vois mal
le jeu généralisée au gardien du stade
de cannes je vais mettre de la peinture
soit 2 du brillant du vernis pour que
lorsqu'il va s'asseoir dessus
et finalement le jour du match je le
voyais il s'assoit et il bouge pas je me
dis bon mais il est bien il doit être
bien coller et finalement les délégués
qui était à côté de moi et sa soirée
déguisée mekhissi qui me de la facture
ici japp ap le gardien mais tu vois tu
t'es trompé c'est pas de la savane c'est
pas le délégué c'était la séquence
c'était bien la voix demande continue
des rouquins pas le football à raymond à
la salle on arrive à rien du tout aux
personnages lalime exceptionnel maradona
avec le but non gelée je vais rencontrer
gelé j'ai joué contre lui au parc des
princes ce contre l'argentine au moins
ça représente quand même quelqu'un qui
recèle et alain îles et les ans une
movida marrakchia annoncé pas les
pétards jacques c'est la coke maradona
jacques hince b6 alors ici il fait comme
ça j'ai dit non c'est pas les pétards
bon c'est la côte nord jacques c'est
l'agglo c'est un peu le à ses principes
tout leur apprendre syrie jouait swiss
excusez moi je voudrais dire c'est un
peu le danger qui guette dans ce milieu
du football roumain sport en général
c'est un peu tous ces gens qui sont aux
alentours qui sont là disposer ou prêts
à tout de suite lorsqu'un jeune quand ça
sort d'être et puis là il ya quand même
des choses à anticiper quand même
malheureux dressé par exemple que pour
en revenir à mon bon suivant anelka vous
pensez qu'il est victime de son
entourage pense pas qu'ils sont avisés
de nos son entourage parce qu'il a et
son entourage c'est sa famille et ses
frères je pense qu'il sera beaucoup plus
protégés d'accord pourra terminer avec
josé touré
josé touré je veux dire je faisais tout
rires et le magicien
oui le joueur le joueur exceptionnel le
joint aussi qui aurait pu on aurait pu -
je crois que maintenant ça va beaucoup
mieux
ouais ce qu'il faut relativement
toujours pensé aubry comme si on était
tard chez les footballeurs y en a qui
pète les plombs quoi c'est pas une
question qui pète les plombs c'est une
question d'être bien accompagné
je crois que dans notre milieu on a on a
besoin de cela d'être bien entouré parce
que si on est mal entourée on est exposé
et comptant les exposés on est exposé à
tous merci merci luis fernandez
le tout gratuit moi je suis une
inconditionnelle de luis et notamment du
psg d'ailleurs j'ai mon temps du bonheur
c'est vrai j'ai ici je vous présente
doliprane luis fernandez de livres a
fait partie du groupe d'intervention
culturelle jalons hermach et elle vous n
le putois là je vous aime tous les jours
j'ai vu une moto grâce à l'ong le
parlement et je vais savoir si on peut
compter sur vous pour une équipe au psg
ou à carhaix je reviendrai à paris
il reviendra